hélène buzzetti paul journet michel ces
objets bonsoir bonsoir je vais rebondir
sur le sujet abordé avec le ministre je
lai barrette le français la protection
du principe ça tombe bien parce qu'à
hélène dans la fonction publique
fédérale ou si un accès inquiète même
celle ci roger d'abord vous attendez à
quoi bon là monsieur minute par du d'un
plan robuste mais c'est pas trop
s'attendait à quoi si je me fie à
linthal entrevue qui vous a donné je
m'attends pas à des changements
législatifs très important ça c'est la
première des choses est ce qu'on va
amender la loi 101 moi je ne vois pas
beaucoup d'amendements la loi 101 là
dedans il ya des affaires
administratives celui d'hier la moitié
des arrondissements de montréal ont pour
leur certificat de l'ol f
oui mais c'est parce quelqu'un qui s'est
plaint qui avait pas de service à
français de la ville de montréal pense
qu on peut demander une des exigences
bureaucratiques mais est ce qu'on va
faire quelque chose qui va toucher
vraiment la langue de travail augmenter
par exemple faire en sorte que les
entreprises de moins de 25 employés
soient soumis à la loi ça il ya personne
que je voulu faire ça même le pq car
c'est au pouvoir on a perdu pas mal à la
limite législatives
ça me fait penser mais seulement des
anecdotes hic à l'époque par journée
mais qu'à monsieur j'en ai barrette
était surtout dire on va légiférer pour
interdire le bush bonjour haye où elle a
évidemment défendu ben non pas pour
faire ça paul bell sont les mesures les
mesures les plus controversées et les
plus costaude on sait déjà que la
coalition avenir québec reparler de
l'avant avec ça par exemple
la loi 101 au cégep ça semble écartée
aussi ce qui relève plus du financement
que des lois par exemple pour
l'agrandissement de dassine ou pour un
nouveau pavillon pour l'université
mcgill
s'ils veulent parler de l'avant on le
sait les spasmes un peu comme celle que
je vois c'est peut-être les entreprises
de 25 à 50 employés
les assujettir à la loi sans ça ça
serait une possibilité mais pour le
reste je pense que la coalition avenir
québec peuvent vraiment récupéré le
dossier du français pour se positionner
comme étant le gouvernement nationaliste
sauf que les faits sont têtus quand même
contrairement à ce que dès jeudi le
ministre le parti québécois le dernier
parti avoir voulu renforcer la loi ça
c'était le gouvernement marois et
pourquoi est ce qu'ils n'ont pas réussi
parce qu'ils étaient minoritaires et
l'a4 au début était avec eux et à la fin
refusé et c'est le plus grand regret de
pauline marois s'est pas avoir renforcé
la protection du français parce qu'elle
n'a pas réussi à convaincre la cac
donc la caq parle beaucoup reste à voir
si elle va être à la hauteur de ses
prétentions
quant à la protection du français hélène
je le disais c'est un sujet aussi qui
rebondit régulièrement tahoua évidemment
la fonction publique fédérale des
employés de gatineau des fonctionnaires
de gatineau qui disent que depuis la
pandémie c'est encore pire
surtout que j'ai de travailler tout le
temps dans la glaise ouais je suis pas
certaine que ce soit d'un point de vue
de fait là que ce soit vraiment très
différent est pris c'est quelque chose
qu'on entend toujours la fonction
publique fédérale c'est une des plus
grosses machines à angliciser au canada
on dit souvent ici à la blague que la
fonction publique canadienne elle n'est
pas bilingue elle est traduite
c'est à dire que ça se passe en anglais
et qu'après on demande aux traducteurs
de passer par la suite
vous savez même même les francophones
souvent lorsqu'il ya par exemple une
nouvelle loi ou une nouvelle politique
il y aura des formes des séances de
formation qui sont offerts soit en
français soit en anglais et les
francophones eux mêmes pour s'inscrire
en anglais pour apprendre la
terminologie en anglais les fameuses
acronyme parce qu'ils savent qu ensuite
dans leur rencontre alors avec leurs
collègues ils seront complètement larié
si eux ils ont appris tous ces mots là
en français alors est-ce que ça a
vraiment changé en pandémie ou
c'est le fait que des tas distance ça
rend les choses plus compliquées quand
on est en langue seconde des fois c'est
un peu plus difficile quand on n'a pas
le visage de la personne devant nous
pour l'interpréter et peut-être que sur
la question du papier donc quand il y
avait des documents qui ont été produits
peut-être qu'effectivement on les a
moins souvent fait traduire dons qu'ils
étaient seulement en version originale
du long voile avait dit l'urgence
souvent hélas nanterre n'a pas le temps
de traduire et on imagine si oui où
celle ci on pourrait bolide usage par le
gouvernement fédéral de google translate
ce serait déjà bien parce que comme ce
document en français et pas dans une
langue qu'on peut appeler le français
d'ottawa mais pas vraiment de france qui
vient de chemin à faire
oui alors la transparence du thème
intéressant qui sait s'applique aux deux
capitales ont vaincu terme sur le groupe
parce qu'aujourd'hui à une charge des
partis d'opposition ont dit vous n'êtes
pas transparent vous nous donnez pas les
critères exacts
quelle maman vous allez ouvrir les
restaurants quelle maman de les rouvrir
les spectacles vous ne donnez pas là le
processus de décision on n'a pas tous
les détails on écoute la réponse de
monsieur le gourou depuis le début ce
soit le début de mon mandat ya deux ans
au début de la pandémie au mois de mars
j'ai eu un mot d'ordre à tous mes
ministres transparence et toutes les
informations qu'on a on la donne
alors monsieur legault dit non puis il
ajoute je commence avec vous pas liées
ajoute les québécois jugeront sacha qui
est très populaire
comme si pour fermer la discussion mais
lui dit que non il dit que les québécois
ont accès à toute l'information que le
gouvernement au ski et pauvres est cela
dit le gouvernement aux des raisons pour
retenir certaines informations le
meilleur exemple
c'était le cas des hommes de couleur ou
de le raisonnement du gouvernement c'est
à dire on veut pas à l'avant se
compromettre en donnant des critères
précis mais rigide qui disent que si une
zone par exemple et orange ou rouge
on va nécessairement adopter telle ou
telle ou telle mesure
on veut se garder un peu de latitude
pour avoir des mesures ciblées mais
adapté en fonction de l'évolution de la
pandémie
ça c'est un premier détail le second
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une espèce de
malentendu au sujet de la transparence
où l'opposition a l'impression que la
cellule de crise
docteur arruda émet des avis formel très
précis écrit et que le gouvernement
décide s'il les respectent ou non
alors que séparément comme ça qui
fonctionne c'est plutôt des discussions
informelles qui aboutissent avec des
consensus et ensuite on les explique
donc c'est pour ça que monsieur legault
a l'impression qu'ils révèlent les
informations qui a révélé en ce sens la
partie a pas d'avis écrit formelle
cacher cela dit si c'est le cas mais
toujours faudrait-il bien les expliqué
en conférence de presse
de façon précise et claire et la
précision et la clarté par moments elle
a manqué il ya eu des conférences de
presse pour le moins précise que
d'autres et ça est sûrement possibilité
de faire mieux ou un michel c'est là
dessus le problème actuellement ce qui
est gens sont fatigués ils sont et ils
ne comprennent parce que le gouvernement
veut pourquoi des bibliothèques sont
fermés et que les librairies sont
ouvertes
pourquoi un gymnase fermé alors que
moins de monde dans un canadien
d'ailleurs ça nous après midi etc etc
etc
et c'est ça qui est actuellement marche
pas pour que les cris les décisions sont
irrationnels pas du tout qu'elle ne sont
pas bien expliquer aux gens et le plus
grand danger
beaucoup d'experts de santé publique
j'avais rêvé de la vigne qui soit votre
émission patrice hier
mission qui dit le problème c'est que la
gouvernance des couples de la population
la population de le suivre parce qu'ils
comprennent pas ce qu'ils veulent faire
plus en plus il ya la fatigue bien
normal c'est l'autre mergault est rendu
et faut qu'il fasse très attention à ça
et c'est pas accueillir des noms à
l'opposition va vous gâter aujourd'hui
qui va me dire les choses on va coûter
monsieur trudeau et glenn qui
aujourd'hui a dit ça va être plate je le
signerai de plantes hiver va être plate
noël va être plate et monsieur legault
qui répondent non pas au fait qu'il va
être plate mais au fait que s'ouvrit
qu'ils soient moins plainte l'hiver
monsieur trudeau vous fermez vos
frontières de l'est là c'est fermé vous
avez tardé l'on sent le coup on est
connue des provinces et les territoires
sont là pour amener des recommandations
sur quoi fermer quoi ne pas faire ou ne
pas aller le gouvernement fédéral comme
on a promis depuis le début on est là
pour appuyer les gens
parce que ce qui est important c'est que
monsieur trudeau qui veut gérer les chs
ld l'homme et qui s'assure de bien gérer
de mieux gérer les frontières au manoir
ça nous fait très mal comme ceux trudeau
ferme pas plus rapidement les frontières
ya plein de gens qui sont rentrés au
québec avec le virus
là c'est très important que monsieur
trudeau garde les frontières fermées
pour un bon bout d'un message est envoyé
la whey clairement à monsieur de legault
veut rendre la monnaie de sa pièce à
monsieur trudeau on n'apprécie pas de se
faire donner des leçons en matière de ch
et s'est levée parce que outre le fait
que ça dépasse des compétences
constitutionnelles le monsieur trudeau
on sent que son désir d'instaurer des
normes nationales c'est un reproche à
québec qu'il ne faut bien gérer les ch
et celle des mets sur la question des
frontières
monsieur monsieur leveaux est un petit
peu malhonnête de ne pas parce que la
frontière elle est fermée et aucune
discussion en ce moment à l'effet qu'on
veut la réouvrir jeu le groove les
impôts oui excusez moi trop de produits
en marque c'est vrai qu'on n'a peut-être
pas fermer la frontière tout de suite
mais on a aucune indication que des
touristes étrangers venant d'étrangers
ici au canada sont à l'origine
d'importantes d'éclosion les études nous
on qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent sur le
québec nous indique que ce sont 247
touriste québécois revenir et ça ça me
ferait qu'on lui pose pas la question
mais cela vaut une somme chasse et je
voyais pas ce que c'est les enseignants
qui revenait tapas pour leur dire venez
que jamais et le canapé de plus je me
dis que se crée patrice la frontière n'a
jamais été fermé mais soyez canadien
tour le droit de revenir au canada il ya
déjà de l'extérieur qui arrive des fois
ça il faut qu'ils aillent faire une
quarantaine il peut accueillir car même
il ya des vols car il ya beaucoup
d'étrangers
je comprends qu'il reste 20 50 parce
qu'on est révélateur d'un certain climat
actuellement
oui parce que c'est une colère non
provoquées ce que monsieur trudeau a dit
aujourd'hui c'était assez inoffensifs
les tentatives
d'ingérence les menaces l'était dans les
précédents jours
monsieur legault revient avec les
critiques sur ce qui s'est passé en mars
rapidement deux choses à dire là dessus
un monsieur legault était pas le seul à
être impatients écoeuré rappelez-vous
montréal s'étaient rendus dans les
aéroports l'administration plantes
elles-mêmes et 2 monsieur trudeau devait
gérer la crédibilité de monsieur tron
qui c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué
décider s'ils ont de vraies ou non les
frontières
merci beaucoup à vous trois merci bonne
fin de soirée bonne journée